en Sudán el conflicto armado entre el
ejército y los paramilitares está
empeorando las condiciones de vida de
los udaneses de forma vertiginosa
saddam es director de una empresa de
energía solar desde que estallaron los
enfrentamientos el 15 de abril no ha
podido dirigir su negocio ni controlar
sus actividades
de golpe tuvimos que olvidarnos de todo
no hay forma de ir a los almacenes ni de
comprobar si los equipos funcionan
no pudimos pagar Los sueldos a nuestros
empleados
estamos en el cuarto día del mes no les
hemos pagado Porque todos los bancos
están cerrados sinceramente es muy
difícil
el sector bancario está Igualmente
convulsionado varios directores de
instituciones financieras han denunciado
saqueos y algunos intentan ahora
trasladar sus sedes fuera de la capital
jartum una situación que supone un
peligro para las empresas sudanesas
por el momento las cosas van bien para
mí pero me preocupa mis empleados
algunos están con sus familias otros se
fueron de Sudán me preocupa que el
negocio se hunda de hecho se hundió con
el colapso de la situación de seguridad
ahora se espera que las empresas
restantes sean saqueadas en cualquier
momento
[Música]
incluso antes de que estallara el
conflicto la economía de Sudán estaba
profundamente estancada lastrada por
décadas de sanciones y aislamiento
internacional bajo el mandato de la
autocrático ex presidente Omar albair
esta nación de rica en recursos
naturales tiene más de 46 millones de
habitantes de los cuales casi una
tercera parte está en riesgo de
inseguridad alimentaria según Naciones
Unidas que cree que casi la mitad son
niños
según los datos más recientes del Banco
Mundial la inflación en este país al
terminar 2021 estaba casi en 400 por